le canada c'est le plus grand pays au
monde
le meilleur pays du monde
l'expression fait partie du folklore un
sentiment qui définit depuis longtemps
l'identité des canadiens le canada
côtoient les grands au palmarès des pays
plus prospère de la planète
gracieuseté d'une économie qui allierait
solides même en temps de crise comment
se partage de richesse qui en profite
c'est l'un des grands enjeux du 21e
siècle il est au coeur des
préoccupations des économistes c'est
assez largement répartie mais il ya eu
une augmentation des inégalités du
partage depuis 30 ans une quarantaine
d'années au canada le fossé se creuse le
revenu des 1% les plus riches ne cesse
de grossir
au canada ce 1 % gagnent en moyenne 380
1300 dollars par an c'est dix fois plus
que le revenu moyen de 38 1700 dollars
qui lui stagne année après année il ya
des forces aux balles qui sont le
changement technologique qui favorise
les gens plus riches et plus éduquées et
la mondialisation qui défavorise les
gens bas de l'échelle donc les forces du
marché favorise une augmentation des
inégalités à 50 ans cette mère de
famille une peluche choix elle déménage
pour plus petits pour moins cher
elle a perdu son emploi en éducation il
ya un an
elle cherche du matin au soir il ne
trouve pas ya de moins en moins d'offres
et les offres sont de plus en plus
élitiste dans le sens où on vous demande
la plupart du temps d'être bilingues
voire trilingues
on vous demande de plus en plus de
diplômes de plus en plus élevés elle n'a
plus d'assurance chômage quatre enfants
à nourrir
pour la première fois de sa vie elle
envisage travailler au salaire minimum
c'est un petit peu dur de passer de
70000 annuel où sa vermine
c'est ce qui vous attend oui c'est ce
qui m'attend si je dois le faire je vais
le faire de toute façon faut que je
fasse quelque chose où je peux pas
rester comme ça même à des salaires
moindres j'ai cherché mais j'ai pas
trouvé ça me fait surtout peur pour mes
enfants qui va aider mes plus jeunes à
comprendre que la vie c'est pas un échec
que l'on peut rebondir si je rebondis
pas de 1940
mackenzie king jusqu'au début des années
80 le canada était un champion de la
redistribution et du partage de sa
richesse avec des programmes sociaux
ambitieux l'assurance maladie la pension
vieillesse et le régime de l'assurance
chômage qui devient le symbole du filet
social canadien
aujourd'hui c'est de moins en moins kg
canada ci-dessus à peu près dans le
milieu le canada est moins inégalitaire
que les états unis d'un côté mais de
l'autre et plus inégalitaire que la
plupart des pays d'europe récession des
années 90 ça fait mal c'est le début de
l'ère de la lutte au déficit
les compressions massives donnent un
coup dur aux mesures sociales dès 1995
le gouvernement libéral de jean chrétien
qui joue même dans la caisse
d'assurance-emploi milliards le régime
considéré comme trésor national va subir
une transformation radicale
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive avec 880 19
heures de travail 911 à de travail et
quelques années elle avait une grosse
hommage aujourd'hui
non ça marche pas ça pourrait être aussi
910 heures ici ou comité action chômage
on aide les sans emploi à se retrouver
dans cette nouvelle réalité
lyon 25 ans est couverte sur leurs
protégés à peu près 80 85 % de chômeurs
canadiens
le lieu un coût qui était d'années se
mêleront et des années 90 mais surtout
sous des libéraux et à partir de 96
cet indice de couverture est tombé à en
dessous de 50% ne s'est jamais relevé et
cette année
on atteint un plancher historique de 38
pour ça dans le si ce service qui n'ont
pas accès aux prestations alors c'est
dramatique
le canada suit de près la tendance
américaine entreprises aller sauf que
par exemple ocde sortait un rapport
étudiant et comparant les différents
régimes d'assurance chômage l'assurance
emploi des pays de l'osce et des
pourceaux marc canadien vous avez des
personnes de tous les pays de l' ocde
pas bon ça les grandes réformes et les
choix politiques des dernières décennies
ont changé le visage de la pauvreté au
canada et pour subvenir aux besoins se
sont plus jamais de jeunes entrepreneurs
comme jean françois archambault qui se
moque du salut ça va oui notre mission à
nous c'est de redonner une équité
sociale de la première qualité que je
pense qu'on doit avoir comme société
c'est de l'empathie il a passé des
années à gérer des cuisines dans des
grands hôtels canadiens la
surconsommation et le gaspillage l'ont
convaincu qu'il avait un rôle à jouer
pour pallier aux inégalités
j'ai des millions de kilos de nourriture
qui sont jetés au canada dans l'année
mon idée est réellement partie de cette
problématique là de la fin il ya des
canadiens et québécois qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim
il ya des chefs qui ont des surplus de
nourriture pourquoi ne pas mettre en
place un système qui permettrait de
rendre la nourriture disponible aux gens
dans le besoin
aujourd'hui l'entreprise sociale qu'il a
mis sur pied la tablée des chefs
nourrie et dieu des milliers de familles
dans le besoin
financé presque entièrement par la fim
entreprises du canada inc ces services
s'étendent du québec calgary
il vise l'europe il mexique on est en
récession
l'argent n'est pas là mais à un moment
donné si les fonds sont paul heures
comment on peut on peut arriver
apprendre des fonds du secteur
philanthropique qui sont des milliards
de dollars à mieux les investir à mieux
les gérer pour créer de l'impact si
j'attendais après l'état pour faire ce
que je fais je pourrais attendre bien
longtemps parce que effectivement il y
en a pour le privé fait partie de la
solution mais jusqu'où peut et doit
aller l'état en 2015 pour renverser la
tendance des philosophies s'affrontent
augmenter les impôts des plus riches
pour redonner à ceux qui en ont plus
besoin
15 $ de l'heure au terme du premier
mandat du npd serait le salaire minimum
les préoccupations de la rue les
manifestations monstres des dernières
années ont éveillé les consciences mais
au canada
aujourd'hui l'écart entre les plus
riches
tous les autres n'a jamais été aussi
grand